Now let's look at the shared memory
version of the same program.
We still have the same size
of the overall array and
the same number of processor cores.
But this time they can all
access the same memory, so
we can just put the whole
array in memory.
We will have the total sum, and each
of them will be computing its own sum.
So, because this array
is in the shared memory,
each processor will sum up
its own part of the array.
The big difference occurs not only here,
where we are actually able to just
access the part of
the array that we want.
But also in how we can compute the sum.
Instead of having to explicitly send.
The elements of the array
to one of the cores.
Here, each core can access the allSum
variable to compute the final sum.
So what they do is they synchronize,
so they have a critical section around
this, and then each core simply
takes the overall sum and adds its
own sum into it, and then frees the lock
so that the next core can do it.
So the course can do this
in any order they want.
We don't have to control that order or
anything.
All that needs to happen is that all
of them have added the sum together.
And now we still have to make sure that
one of the cores prints out the sum.
But because this can
be done in any order,
Core Zero could be the one that
does this first and then prints out
only its part of the sum because
the others has not updated this yet.
So we need to add code here, to have
what's called a barrier, where basically
we put a synchronization here that
makes all of the cores wait for
everybody to arrive before they proceed.
To ensure that Core Zero when
it does this, does it only when
everybody else has arrived to this point
and has incremented the sum already.
One of the nice properties of this is
not only that it makes it more explicit
who does what, so that we don't have
to think about this as being basically
four different versions of code.
There is no need to
distribute the array.
The whole array is all of
the time in the shared memory.
We just choose who is
going to access what.